et ça l'a fasciné.
Albert Einstein n'est plus qu'un gars blanc mort
avec des cheveux bizarres.
C'est Oncle Albert. (Rires) Mon fils voulait savoir :
« Qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ? Qu'est-ce que c'était E=MC² ? »
Tout n'est pas rose cependant.
Je me suis trouvé un lien avec Jeffrey Dahmer, le tueur en série,
mais c'est du côté de ma femme.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Je veux que ce soit bien clair. Désolé, chérie.
Troisièmement, l'interconnexion.
Nous avons tous le même ancêtre
pas besoin de croire dans la version biblique.
Les scientifiques parlent du Y chromosomique d'Adam
et d'Eve mitochondriale.
C'était il y a de 100 000 à 300 000 ans.
Nous avons tous un peu de leur ADN en nous.
Ce sont nos arrière-arrière-arrière- arrière-arrière-arrière --
continuez ainsi 7 000 fois --
grand-parents.
Cela signifie que nous sommes tous
cousins biologiques.
Les estimations varient mais il est probable que
votre cousin le plus éloigné sur terre
soit à peu près votre 50e cousin.
Nous partageons les mêmes ancêtres mais aussi les descendants.
Si vous avez des enfants et qu'ils ont des enfants,
regardez à quelle vitesse les descendants s'accumulent.
Dans dix, douze générations,
vous allez ainsi avoir des milliers,
des millions de descendants.
Quatrièmement, un monde plus aimable.
Je sais qu'il y a des querelles de famille.
J'ai trois fils, je vois bien comment ils se battent.
Mais je pense qu'il existe un trait chez l'homme
qui fait que l'on traite mieux sa famille que les étrangers.
Je pense que cet arbre va être une mauvaise nouvelle pour les fanatiques
parce qu'ils vont devoir se rendre compte
qu'ils sont cousins avec des milliers de gens
appartenant à un groupe ethnique
qui pourrait leur poser problème.
Si vous regardez en arrière,
beaucoup des choses horribles que nous nous sommes infligés
viennent du fait qu'un groupe considère l'autre comme sous-humain.
Vous ne pourrez plus le faire.
Nous n'appartenons pas seulement à la même espèce mais encore à la même famille.
Nous partageons 99,9% de notre ADN.
Enfin, cinquièmement,
c'est l'effet de démocratisation.
Certaines généalogies ont une tendance élitiste.
Certains disent, par exemple : « Je descends de Marie, reine d’Écosse
vous non, donc vous ne pouvez pas faire partie de mon country club. »
Cela va être difficile à faire maintenant car tout le monde a un lien de parenté.
Je descends de Marie, reine d’Écosse --
par alliance, mais ça compte.
C'est vraiment une époque fascinante
dans l'histoire de la famille,
parce que tout change très vite.
Il y a le mariage gay et les donneurs de sperme,
des mariages consanguins à un niveau jamais vu.
Cela rend certains de mes cousins les plus conservateurs un peu nerveux
mais je pense que c'est une bonne chose.
que plus la famille parle d'intégration, mieux c'est.
Nous aurons plus de gens susceptibles de prendre soin de nous
et comme la cousine au 16e degré de ma tante,
Hillary Clinton, a dit --
(Rires) --
il faut un village.
J'ai toutes ces centaines et milliers, ces millions de nouveaux cousins.
Je me suis demandé ce que je pouvais faire en sachant ça.
J'ai alors décidé
de faire une fête.
Voilà ce que je vais faire
et vous êtes tous invités.
L'année prochaine, l'été prochain,
je vais organiser ce que j'espère être
la plus grande et la meilleure réunion de famille de l'histoire.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Je veux vous voir là-bas.
Je veux vous y voir.
Ce sera au Panthéon de la Science de New York.
Un lieu super,
c'est aussi sur le site de l'ancienne Exposition Universelle.
Je trouve ça adéquat
car ce sera une réunion de famille doublée d'une exposition universelle.
Il y aura des expositions, de la nourriture, de la musique.
Paul McCartney n'est qu'à onze degrés,
donc j'espère qu'il va emmener sa guitare.
Il n'a pas encore répondu à l'invitation mais croisons les doigts.
Il y aura un jour de conférence,
un jour avec des cousins fascinants.
Il est encore tôt mais j'ai déjà des réponses.
Cass Sunstein, mon cousin, qui est, peut-être,
le plus brillant juriste qui soit, sera là pour parler.
C'est un ancien membre de l'administration d'Obama.
De l'autre côté du spectre politique,
George H.W. Bush, numéro 41, le père
a accepté d'y participer.
Nick Kroll, le comédien,
Dr. Oz et bien d'autres encore.
Le plus important, c'est, bien sûr, vous.
Je veux que vous soyez présent.
je vous invite à aller sur GlobalFamilyReunion.org.
Cherchez où vous vous placez sur l'arbre,
parce que ce sont de grandes questions, la famille, le clan.
Je ne connais pas toutes les réponses
mais j'ai plein de parents intelligents,
vous y compris.
Je pense qu'ensemble, nous allons trouver la solution.
Nous ne pourrons résoudre ces problèmes qu'ensemble.
De cousin à cousin,
je vous remercie. J'ai hâte de vous voir.
Au revoir.
(Applaudissements)